internet pro l'outing la démocratie ça
c'est la grosse question je contacte
internet relève la démocratie internet
c'est une infrastructure jeu puis promue
à la démocratie c'est le world wide web
l'internet c'est uniquement un
dispositif d' échanges de fichiers entre
différents réseaux numériques
le world wide web chez un système
éditorial qui est apparu en 1993 grâce à
un drop et qui a permis une
extraordinaire multiplication de pages
web de sites web blogs et qui a créé une
effervescence formidable qui a été tué
il y a une dizaine d'années par les
réseaux sociaux les plateformes et les
smartphones
aujourd'hui il faut réinventer le web et
oui le web veut absolument permettent le
développement d'une nouvelle forme de
démocratie et à travers cela valorise et
l'infrastructure qu'est l'internet
c'est la tâche pour moi de l'europe dans
les années qui viennent
aum